hi everyone it's jerry this is game five
from the 2021 feed a world chess
championship match between jan
nepomnichi playing on the white end
and magnus carlson
going into game five were level
two points a piece
let's have a look
another e4 by yan in each of his white
games it's been e4 so far
and we have another roy lopez
we follow game
three
until this point right here
in game three the reply was bishop b7
a handful of moves later black
experienced some difficulties
had to come up with the clever plan
he did
underdeveloping the bishop
and then going to e6
in this game it's rook b8 and so the
bishop stays trained along this natural
diagonal is only ever a blink away from
challenging white's very active bad
bishop
and keeps an eye out for that f5 square
he may at some point need to take the
knight if it gets there the queen knight
with rook b8
there is a downside
and that downside is
black gives up control over the a file
so white gets that initiates the capture
on b5
and white follows with h3 once more
as we saw in earlier royal lopez games
white is sidestepping martial
attack like play by black
instead of h3 if c3 is in there we can
have
this gambit
where white can pick up the e pawn
and as compensation for being down a
pawn black can start
looking for these offensive moves
king side play especially now that
white's king knight
is
on the sidelines and white's queen side
miners are still home
this is where
some of the compensation lies with
black so
white's not going for that instead it's
h3
for the next move at least
white keeps the c3 square vacant
maybe the knight wants to go there only
after d6 do we now have c3 so if black
really wants to
play d5 that will have cost to tempo
and from here we have black justifying
the rook post
the b file will be peeled open soon
enough
next up it's d3 so this caught my
attention
uh i thought to myself when c3 is in
isn't the idea to build in the center
put two pawns there
that is a way forward and i want to put
some moves in here
so we could get a feel for
different
central play
so if d4 is on this is how black can
follow
you chip away with the pawn
b takes c first
now if the knight recaptures
that would mean the queen is overloaded
so this isn't uh an option for white
knight takes d4 and
black is doing well
so you'd have to recapture with the pawn
black continues to chip away
and now that this ideal pawn center is
present it needs to be struck straight
away and this is the proper way to do it
d5
e5 knight e4 and this is as far as i
want to go
this guy
uh well white has some space with the
pawn on e5 black on the other hand has a
knight on white side of the board
with the move played in the game d3
what might we say
white
does not want to allow a black knight to
get into e4
white is staying very strong
on e4
what follows now is b takes c
now
in the game we had b take c3 here's one
other way
this structure can change in the center
in the event of knight
captures on c3
well first of all notice by capturing
with the knight yes you're developing a
piece
but at the same time this knight
has two pretty good options at some
point
how play might follow if knight captures
on c3 is some something like this
we could eventually see a white queen
arriving in the center but at the end
in the end here black has a majority in
the center
dark square bishop the only bishop
remaining
we can play with
pawns on light
maybe even look forward to converging
one day on f2
this is another way the structure can
change
the move played in the game b take c
is primarily aimed at the knight on c3
excuse me c6
this piece currently has no squares now
because of this recapture
white's playing against this knight
black needs to do something about that
this knight needs a new square
the follow-up d5 is a step in the
direction of one day opening up a square
for this knight
the bishop still has to move but
you got to get this pawn moving first
this bishop currently doesn't have a
square
and this knight doesn't have a square
okay black frees his position
some with d5
and
is open to giving up a pawn with this
advance as well
now the reply is knight b
to d2
if white goes for the e pawn in this
position
this is what white can play
post the bishop on e6
and there are a couple tricks
that black would have up his sleeve
the main one knight takes c3
which unleashes which would unleash a
second attacker on b3
and bishop f6
there's a lot of stuff
on this main dark diagonal
considered best is for white to part
ways with the light square bishop
okay
in the game it's knight b to d2
the d-pawns are exchanged
a square is opened up for this knight
finally has a square
queen c2
there will be no
coordinated pressure on f7
flight square on board as well with h6
the queen knights transferring to the
corresponding
g file squares
bishop e3
and now the biggest thing in the game
move 19 for carlson is
queen e8
what was maybe going through his mind
here well something i could
point out is
black needs to be in a position to
work around
a white knight should it ever arrive on
f5
sometimes
you'll want to knock it out straight
away bishop takes knight but it's not
working in this case
so
this is the more natural looking square
but
if queen to e7
there's this move and you can't take the
night why not well let's see what
happens
your night's hit where should it go
you have to go to the corner and if you
have to go the corner
you might as well resign
you can't go here because of this your
queen's dead
so
black needs to
stay out of the reach of the knight
he goes to e8 which is supporting bishop
to e6
and
what more does black have to think about
well
there's this possibility there's a way
the structure can change on the queen
side
now the move played after queen to e8
was rook to d1 but let's once more look
at how this structure can change
if black excuse me if white played c4
how is black reacting to this there's a
couple interesting
continuations the computer points out
one is to say
i'm not even going to allow you to put
your pawn on my side of the board i'm
not going to give you that space
advantage
black can play c5 in this position
during the live stream i
pointed out that if this structure is on
board
there'd probably be a race to get a
knight
right
a uh
let's say a white knight
on d5 and a black knight
on d4
but there's also an interesting option
for white in this position to quickly
circle the bishop into d5
these this is a big square a minor piece
there maybe even a rook there
an important intersection square in the
position are these
uh d4 and d5 squares
so that would be an interesting
follow-up
also black could maybe say to himself
i'm okay if this pawn gets here
with this variation bishop e6
bishop a4
queen c8
allow this one and i think the black
pieces are doing all right i don't know
how inconvenienced
the white or excuse me the black pieces
are because this pawn
is on c5 i don't think it's
too disruptive i think the black pieces
are finding all right squares in this
position
okay anyhow a lot for black to consider
on this move 19.
yawn does not go for c4 he's playing
still within the structure and we have
more maneuvering
so our repositioning here rook rook on e
to d1
bishop e6
bishop a4 i thought there might be a
little back and forth repetition with
the bishops ducking each other
but play does continue with knight d2
light square bishop's gone queen's gone
and a pair of rooks exchange we have
just transitioned from middle game
quickly to ending
where black is the one who still has
some pressure
excuse me white still has some pressure
on black
rook a6
this
is a point white is ready to target
in three ways
so black is now going on the defensive
98 anticipating this pressure
some improvement for the king
this right here is an excellent square
for a knight
there are two routes there
but why give
white an option to maybe knock out the
knight
so it pivots on
first f8
and then gets to e6 so whenever we have
this type of structure in the center
this ram structure
a black knight on e6 a white knight on
e3 will very often stand well
and similarly if we had a ram structure
on the d file
we had a knight on a white knight on d3
a black knight on d6 would stand very
well
they have many good options
currently
well after this night
after this last move this
is black's best piece
on e6 this is important to
uh
this is important to know this knight
wants
that e6 square needs that e6 square
from here we have knight c4
and it's
not the greatest move to have to make
but
d6 needs to be defended
uh directly
um
yeah black is
curling up in a ball here
but
it's it's necessary something i thought
of is well can you
you know instead of babysitting d6 can
you go on the offensive
you know
go after the c pawn
that's it's it's not a good idea to play
rook to b3 now if white followed with a
bunch of captures on d6 this would turn
out all right an even position
there's a problem though if this rook
goes to b3 white doesn't capture away on
d6 white goes to the back rank and says
you're in a pin and you cannot easily
get out of it
white will end up winning a pawn
in the following way there's rook b8 and
you can't take here
all right rook takes c there's knight
takes here and
you're in this pin
okay at minimum white is going to win a
pawn if this rook gets excited about
going after the c pawn
so
black's in a prevent has to babysit d6
and from here we have f3 this move i
didn't
really appreciate during the game i
didn't quite understand why f3 is played
instead of g4
um what i overlooked is that if you were
to play g4 you're
allowing black a new possibility with
this knight
just drawing a lot of attention to this
knight being a great piece but let's
also not forget that that this bishop on
e3 is also pretty good
if white played g4 instead of f3 this is
a new possibility for black striking at
these two
it seems like white has to give up the
bishop for night
and now that this pawn is no longer on
h6 black will find it much easier to
shoo
this knight away you have to worry about
knight takes h6
okay
in this game it's first
a small step f3
and now we have f6
f6 is
saying something
f6 is saying i am okay with your knight
on f5
i'm going to work around it
i think this because
if black really wants to
kick this knight away
he'll start with h5
get out of the way
uh well
move move the pawn so that he can next
play g6 and you're not going to be
losing the pawn on h6 anymore
uh
yeah g6 is nearby black can go ahead and
control the f5 squares what i'm getting
at
he's okay
black has determined that it's okay to
work around this knight
so he's going with f6 allowing white to
clamp down on this structure
this pawn will eventually arrive on h5
not much you can do about that
king f7 now this knight is secure
and because it's secure this bishop is
now free to move
h4
bishop f8
king e2
useful
no entry points
knight d6
and this is
an important moment in the game
there's tension between both knights
and
well let's consider an option here by
white in the game knight takes knight
was played
uh
if knight d2 is played which one do i
want to show first
i'll show this one
uh let's duck
this knight exchange
now
if black takes here
that's not a good idea why would be
winning
why
because this knight is scared away from
its favorite square
and we can very easily arrive at
a position you'd see in plenty of chess
books good night versus bad bishop
black is in big trouble
it's important to keep control over this
to not allow white to control e6 with
the pawn
this knight is poison
so
knight d2
shouldn't be met with knight takes
knight
black would play knight b5
um if white ducks the knight exchange
this is good for black knight b5 there
is now not a great way for white to
defend this pawn the top suggestion is
to bring your knight back to b1 well
if you have to play like that why why
why not exchange the knights
you know why not play
knight c4 takes on d6
there's a cool tactic that i'm trying to
get to
and that is this move seems like it's a
convenient way to defend the pawn right
you're you're not just there to defend
the pawn but you keep some pressure on
this pawn on c7 i don't know how
inconvenient it is for black because
this knight's there but
here's a cool tactic that's available to
black if this rook is on c6
black can follow with g6 now
and well
this pawn is
it seems like it's up for grabs but
here's the trick
after g6 knight takes bishop takes
bishop takes
see the trick
the knights have some fun
and we see that the rook gets picked off
uh one other variation instead of knight
d2
suppose knight a3 not even allowing
knight to b5
well once more we can have g6 and this
knight is
well either have to take the knight or
go back to an awkward square
this pawn is poison
knight takes h6
can be met with bishop takes and after
bishop takes you're ready
uh-oh
this bishop is trapped
king g6 nearby
if you want to stop king g6 you'd have
to play this
but then this rook could hunt the bishop
anyhow a couple fancy tactics
that may be right around the corner
a night fork on d4 as we observed when
the rook is on c6 and this
bishop trap
with first g6 and then g5
okay in this game
the knights are exchanged
and
white is able to clamp down this knight
is now secure
no driving it away
but black backs up
everything is strung together for black
a little little bit of space here
tough to break down black's position
there's plenty of support on this base
point and there isn't a great way for
white to disrupt this coordination
this is uh
a masterful piece on e6
so from here we have rook a5
what's the try here
the tries to try and change the
structure
black doesn't want to ever really move
this pawn this pawn is doing a good job
in
securing the king
all right as soon as this pawn moves
there's some possibility for rank checks
so we keep this on the home square
rook a5 attempting to do what
go to d5 the move played in the game
and white is saying please take me
black does not bite to exchange rooks
you're losing
that's how serious this is these three
pawns
clamp down
on these four
and white essentially has
an extra pawn on the
center slash
queen side
so
no rook captures
we maintain our knight on e6
and
white really doesn't have any better
than to
try and offset this black rook
all right there are no entry points for
the white rook
and this rook can poke around here maybe
targeting
the c pawn
given an opportunity maybe
it gets to the a file and pinpoints f3
no progress to
to be made at the end of the day this
one goes as far as move 43
we have a repetition here
nothing more to play for
it's solid it's coordinated for black
and white and yeah no no good progress
from this point on so
a fifth game
in
the books
and another
very high quality
game
let's have a look at the tail of the
tape on this one
there we go
another flat liner
super high quality
six average centipalm loss for each
player
just gets more intense
two and a half points apiece going into
game six
all right we will see what happens
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you